và giảm đau kia này, nó có lấy cái xe dọ
có thậm mẹ nghe nè, tìm đọng, có tức cái xe dọng, chặn chương
có mấy cái xe dọng, có mấy cái xe dọng, có mấy cái xe dọng
và giễn chờ sức dụng nhồng vào phá yên
có thậm hồi lâu đọng
Chúng chú đúc nha nè nè nè nè nè
Anh làm được không?
Sơn anh em em em có gì kể giấy?
Láu chí sẽ rẻ vào xe dọng, có chồng có đôi rồi
Chị không có mũ bỏ, nó chỉ có này
Chị khi mình chú quen là bí để cái người sẽ khả cho mình
Còn kiểu họ ở đây, để kính nghệ khác trực lạm
Hẹn hả như vậy mua
Chịnh báo mình đi đâu
Thằng bố ơi
Hẹo ngoài nó cũng điện
Mò thúc này đi á
Mình em thể ngoài nó cũng không có đi ngoài đi ngoài đi ngoài đi ngoài
Này là sao
Tháng giảm bố dú lần rồi
Để không dễn tỏ nó đều có cái gì đôi
Với hồi thấy không có tất cả với gì đôi ra kẻ như vậy có chè mình
Lời
Tếm lâu
Này máy lần nữa
Sẽ đối cùng tình trảy sẽ đoạn quá vậy
Kẹt hỏi máy ngạch
Khi đo rồi
Trang chính rồi này mua
Hôm có lần nữa cũng trình này
Hôm quen, vui trình có như này nữa
Chị thì có miền mà thông tán
Vui lâu mở hả?
Hồi thưa hồi thưa hồi thưa dây mà không mất
Trong trưng là nó sẽ rất chút lòng.
Hãy là cái cách giống cố vây dàng tòn.
Sì là mình làm việc, chứng cao.
và hay quy định đứng, đứng ở đây là các bạn.
Chân 2 mẹ thêm mình mắt bột mình dàng tòn.
Mọi người có bị phát em tòn mình có trên kỳ lên càng, lỗi mở, dành dạo,
mất kia bảo bệt mình.
Bảo bệt kia em tòn là cái phối cùng.
để bảo bệt vinh bạn, cho một người ai...
Rồi xong, cho bệp, bệp, bệp, bệp, bệp, ở nhà.
Cấm về choice.
Bệp mình thọc hội với đồ ai.
Cục triếp, quýi ai.
Còn ta trên cao.
Cỳ học như là nó là bảo không chủ nè.
Ời xác của mình đỉnh 2 quy định đồng tuyên para liên, phát mạnh dài.
Yên nó.
Ời, tụi 2,
nó này là chăm VH3.
Mất là VH2.
Hãy chống chừng hả mơ mơ mơ mỡ hộ nữa trở như nào
ở đây là mình chỉ đi cái bất mục trá đó là nhà ở đâu rồi
còn người trở tập tế ở ngoài thống trường
hãy phó lất là cái nhiều thử dụng như xa cầu
có cả thích bị gôn em rất là nhiều
rồi hả em
ch ic cho hả hả vẫn còn
cứ có khרה mẫu nữa
chứ nơi ở đây rồi
tại sao không còn tạm của những cậm của FN
expertise muốn hỏa
rồi, nó đã đi bây giờ sao的時候 này mình còn traject thì cũng báo lên
hả em còn vuyin want phải quyết địch
đây là
một người tập tếm đồng và mua trập tếm đo
cứ tập tếm tốt
nó máo trập kê nhấn mình
thì nh形 gửi đá máo tưới mạnh mình
cái này cảnh xong cỚn nữa
có cái em tọng nói là cái bánh tháp k古 cầu
để báo vào đây
mình vời mình gần tốt đó
dữ nào ở trong tốt em
Nói này, lỗi quần là thích quy định của anh chưa được chuyển chà.
Đáng ra là cái lỗi này của anh là đánh triển mẹo khai.
Nhưng mà là ngày em cho anh biết chuyển định và cảm có con thấy không.
Hồi anh có có có biết chuyển định, ghi đủ không tất nhá.
Nhưng ngày này, mình sợn ngọt,
nhưng thần ngày này thẳng của em, mình này thì chặt trẻ là nhân giáo thì tâm bột của anh.
Hãy đều dây gòn không, đều dây nhân giáo.
Không, mình là là phía mình bán gì lắm.
Mình cũng có thể đẹp dành cho dành dạo
Thật phải đẹp dành cho dành lộng gái
Nhìn thấy cái gì đó là cái gì đó
Một dành dạo
Công mình đấu cặng cái đầu ăn to lắm
Chỉ vẫn này là mình cũng không hợp hợi
Một dành dây mình là dây gọi thôi
Lẹo chè của nó quen rồi
Mỏa quen rồi
Chỉ khi mình chú quen là binh
Đẹo thì chỉ lần táng ở đây đó
thì nó sẽ khai giấc mình
mình tọng nó bây giờ mình không thấy rồi
này là
ăn còn, tính mạnh mình
bởi vì cào mình phải đa ở đây rồi
nó dạng cấu mình kêu ra khai khác
mới ở đây là mấy nhà tầu khác
này thì nó dịch vào
bà yếu dùng của mình ở đây nó trong chúi
ăn còn, nó châu rồi
có không thì nó kì mình xuống không châu rồi
Đo anh còn chào
Nhưng mà nó thì có đo anh có chào
Đo anh có chào
Cô bột trình
Anh có chung một tập hệ
Nhưng mà bè là không phải em còn nữa có hệ
Đo anh có có đo anh có có đo anh có có đo anh có có
Thì anh lên binh để lạ
Em còn nhiều đây nhắc
Công nhằm đoổi mũ đo nhỏ
Nhưng mà sẽ không phải có em còn nữa
Đó rất nhiều thấy
Hình có thể là
Sì dẫn một cái quân hóa em còn cho
Đó phải tên dễ
Công nhằm nhiều thế nào
Hồi không có hoa hình cho
Bà kết quý cộng nữa là đây đã báo rồi thì họ họ giao về
họ không có có mẹ gì là
là không có mẹ mình đã thật không
Nó ngay bàng toàn được hình thùng nhìn
Tình bây giờ mình sẽ mây
Điều mình đã đi vào thứ gì rồi
Nhìn này như không hay
Cảm ơn phòng tý tất cảnh này